oh my
assalamu alaykum wa rahmatullah wa
better care to brothers and sisters
welcome back to the reality show part 4
the video is called I want a pie his
wife and obviously we all want a pie his
wife but it's not what the videos about
my whole topic is based upon basically
the hypocrisy and double standards are
certain men so as you know you know some
people out there some men out there have
girlfriends are looking for girlfriends
you know but when I ask them a question
regarding which you see the clip in a
minute you know how would you react for
example if your sister had a boyfriend
they get really angry and one of the
moves that I lose my composure you know
really affected them I just wanted to
show the hypocrisy you know when they
have a girlfriend it's okay but when
their sister or their daughter or etc
has a boyfriend they don't like it you
know that's just this what the whole
show is about basically and also some
men that go out there and sleep around
have girlfriends but when it comes to
marriage is like now when a woman that's
on touch I want a pie his wife you know
we're gonna give like talk about hadith
and also how men reacted to certain
questions we asked them now as you know
my channel has moved from Muslim youth
movement you can still watch reality
part 1 2 & 3 on Muslim youth movement
but from now on all the reality shows
would be on my channel so inshallah
subscribe and also you can check out the
videos at the end of the link at the end
of the video as you know a couple of
weeks ago the video about the lid
because somebody reported it and I think
it's one of the guys I interviewed
obviously I didn't cover their face but
we told them and was doing an interview
but anyway you know maybe I should have
covered their face so basically enjoy
the video and don't forget to subscribe
Salam alaikum I see right after the
clips do you have a girlfriend yes I
okay well I wouldn't know it how would
you feel how would you like if your
sister had a boyfriend and she wasn't
she was going out of someone and you
know
but do be able to get what I'm trusting
yeah yeah I guess it's like a long-term
slavery like this year we don't know we
don't know if it's long-term but she's
going out with some guy and you don't
know what they do but they're going out
and obviously they give a boy a
relationship you know what really
happens like how would you feel as a
brother hey won't be comfortable with it
you won't be comfortable yeah yeah you
wouldn't like it I wouldn't like it
okay how about okay my favorite question
is basically if you was to get married
yeah and if your wife had let's say for
example had sexual relationships before
before with coconut guys would you
accept that and marry her would you say
no heywhat accepted I won't mind it
forever I would have to accept okay okay
you mind it but you're saying I'll
accept it yeah because I didn't they if
if for example if you if if I go around
and do these kind of stuff with kills
like obviously I'm not gonna expect my
wife to be pious or virgin do you get it
because I'm doing it yeah what I'm
saying is I won't mind it when she had
sexual relationships before yeah but
because I love her and I well yeah you
know I I need to accept it you need to I
don't want to accept it but I need to
you don't want to accept about you look
so yeah have you go girlfriend yes I do
okay now I would ask you is this year
you find out that your sister has a
boyfriend
how would you feel how would you have I
wouldn't really like it I mean it is
something you know being a Muslim it's
not really a part of our culture and
everything yes but when I go out do it
it's a different thing because me my
girlfriend she's not Muslim yeah she's
not so I don't think it's it's wrong in
their culture okay but it is in our so I
wouldn't really be you know I wouldn't
appreciate it I would try to find out
who that guy is and you don't try to
tell her that this is not the right
thing this is not how you do it okay Jay
but don't you think here like this is
what we're getting I don't you think
it's a bit like okay first off use me
like alright you got a girlfriend yet
then how does it work when you say okay
about my sister I know it's right I'm
losing myself here I know how it is yeah
isn't that bit double standard can you
tell us can you tell us where the
problem arises that's when it becomes
hard that's when it becomes hard that's
how
I mean if she starts asking me questions
about it okay what if you do it yeah
then it's hard for me to explain to her
yeah this is the hard part this is where
I would actually go blank
listen you go girlfriend yeah girlfriend
yeah okay how would you feel if your
sister came home and said you know what
look I'm dating this guy and you don't
know if he's serious I know but she's
saying okay I move some guy it's fun if
I you know you won't mind that okay
right how about you're getting married
yeah okay and then your wife comes up to
you and says yeah look
previously off I had these [ __ ] cover
relations and she was just take over
sorry I should be non-experience you
saying look I was in free fall other
guys and she was sexually do you I'm
trying to say this happened how would
you feel would you say you know what now
I'm gonna carry on with it so would you
say you know I don't mind it was a past
I'm just gonna leave it right before
getting married it's not happening right
before we get married right before you
get married it's not you know you're not
taking it no I'm not taking it okay if
it was all of us supposed to come out
turned a rainy day okay turn am not Rob
just before we get married
not before engage doctor and engagement
either no that's all day in stages do
you have a girlfriend no no okay let's
suppose you have a girlfriend yeah okay
yeah and how would you feel for example
if your sister your sisters you have
sisters how would you feel if your
sister came home and said she's dating
she's got a boyfriend baby we're gonna
find out who he is
make sure he's all right remember what
you know him you know I'm here with
Carlos Collins I want to show his face
for certain reasons he knows best
okay Carlos do you have a girlfriend
yeah you have a girlfriend yeah okay
and Carlos what would you do if you see
that came home one day and said that you
have a um she's got a boyfriend I would
be angry
oh you'd be angry okay all right so
excuse me for asking you this yet but so
you can have a girlfriend but when he
says has a boyfriend you'll be angry is
any reason why I stopped you standards
listen you know to be honest I'm a man
right and my sister
you wouldn't know how to decide who is a
good you know good fella
good chap you know okay all right so
what about your girlfriend that you're
with nod did the same for her that she
can't decide for herself as well well I
decided for her right you decided for
her
okay let's pause on that question so
that's the opinion so how about if your
wife yeah you're getting married there
and your wife she's she's had previous
relationships he's been with different
guys would you tolerate that would you
would you carry on the marriage or would
you say now I'm gonna have them no
clean-sheet bro prefer clean sheet you
prefer clean sheet
okay so isn't that double standards you
can go around do what you want just
don't get me wrong yet well you can go
around do what you want but when it's
when I'm trying to say so when your wife
is gone out there yeah and maybe she's
made mistakes often you wanna know them
it's my right now I can decide whatever
standards I just think that woman who do
such things should really think twice
because like who wants marry something
like that who wants to marry someone
like you
now guys do you have a girlfriend now I
wanna ask you a question yet you found
out for your friends your sister has a
boyfriend yeah
what would you reaction be again mental
it's my composure find out who the guy
is
and I tend to stay away from okay now
I'm gonna ask you a question yeah now
obviously now you have your say if you
had a girlfriend yeah okay now don't you
think it's a bit of a double standard
here where you say okay you have a
girlfriend yeah but when it comes to you
sister you're like oh hold on a second
hold on a second like I'm just giving
you a completely different story okay
like that cuz my sister wears a
headscarf yeah I thought respect that
yeah you do nice yeah yeah
yes completely different story you're a
guy he's a girl you're supposed to look
off the yellow sister you get me okay
but I'm gonna be real with you but what
about the person you're with what about
Jesus sister to a person as well
yung-chun see that depends depends of
family allow it or not they don't then
I'll stay away from her
you're gonna get married your wife tells
you that she had a pasta yeah
would you cost relationships and stuff
after you do I'm trying to say would you
carry on or would you be like nah nah
nah nah man wants a virgin
I told you depends on the feelings tools
ago we might I really love the girl but
I'll go be remove you again yeah okay if
you wanna know if you should be a virgin
yourself a new girlfriend no no yes yeah
okay okay how would you like it if you
go home your sister you found out that
you sisters business aa boyfriend
how would you feel would you like it not
particularly
okay ba isn't that double standards for
example you're saying you can have
girlfriends but when you're gonna be
protected when you got here so you're
telling me that is that a guy thing
yeah it's your family from my
perspective yeah
how come it's okay for you to have a
girlfriend but now when it comes to your
sister maybe that's somebody else's yeah
it's just a family thing like I don't
think anyone's got that perception that
it's wrong when it's with someone else
because it's outside of the household is
not someone you know yeah but and you
think yourself is a good guy do you have
a girlfriend so you girlfriend yeah okay
all right so what would you do yeah if
you found out your sister has a
boyfriend
how would you let me get this right yeah
so you're telling me you can have a
girlfriend but when is your sister
having a boyfriend ego switch is
hypocrisy
my sister oh it's different now now for
real for real this is brother Ibrahim a
Manchu yet no joke so bro you know what
you're not here yeah I'm just trying to
write you know you know how the reality
show if works a couple of them even in
the first one obviously what lies you
give these guys out there who go around
sleep around with guilt do all kinds of
crap but when it's their boyfriend when
it's their sister they get all
protective so what does a second I don't
need fingers what if someone did that to
their own sister
and they behave in a band when they
going out with someone maybe I'm trying
to say
I advise duty because you're married now
asleep and you if you went through that
stage mashallah you know you didn't get
into all that girlfriend your boyfriend
think how did you do and how could you
advise the Bermuda okay I'm gonna go
sooner to see them and also the door
guys so I'm why they come brothers and
sisters I can't just to clarify no I
don't have a girlfriend
technically I do because my wife is a
girl and she's my friend the prophet
sallallaahu I do a-stannin was
approached by a boy and you won't know
this hadith but I want you to look at it
differently he was approached by a boy
so call the Haleiwa sellers who said
that yeah I'll put a lock make zina how
miserable for me because he was that
desperate like he needed to in it you
needed a beat it arms in the producer
said I'm basically said to him would you
like for someone to do this to your mom
or to your sister and the boy was like
nah of course not obviously another
problem she said I'm obviously you know
the message what through two men you
realize you know that you know we don't
want that someone to do that to one of
my own women we're not gonna do that
someone else's woman right and the
president made the offering no you know
what the scholars say about this hadith
they say that if a man comes to hear
about this and understand this right but
if they violate someone else is sister
this is to make it violated then one of
the ways that a lot punishes them is by
making sure that happens to their sister
by making sure that happens to their
daughter but making sure that happens to
their mom or your auntie and so on and
Salam alaikum brothers and sisters
welcome back and you saw what we saw and
we only we experience is always there
yeah it's fun unless crazy man is you
know the double standards the hypocrisy
out there man you know
where does this come from and how did he
gets kind of mentality about Allah I
know you know I think it's just I think
that's creeped in inside of alike
especially the Muslim because there's
nothing there's nothing to do this I
mean obviously it's not never from us
anything but obviously when we're in a
society this is obviously that like for
most music movies and all these they
have like you know in the music videos
the man is gone or the go that's a man
and they will come to him and obviously
when it's the other way around you don't
see a woman in her video because then
it's like other discos yeah you know
what it isn't it so it's just like it
script within our Senate like it's just
somehow and in the movies and I it's
just a Lardon just it's being forced
down my throat and then now is just
picking up a thing that we don't know
it's in it you see in the video the guy
you asked him that this and that your
girlfriend in a sauna and I'm like yeah
yeah then any awesome about his sister
the guy this world I've seen his work he
goes oh my sister I found out I lose my
composure yeah that's a bit were like
you know he was so affected by emotion
yeah and basically but you see the
hypocrisy yeah but also you do see these
men out there most of them they like
they understand it's wrong they know
it's wrong that they justified they
justify themselves like you saw it
because when we do when you tell them
that oh yes that's someone else's this
is just the way you know like really
they're like in the head of thing now
you know he's got a point but then I at
the same time you know you know yeah
basically a couple of days of up forms
that were working on this project
yeah I watched his videos it really hit
me hard man you know basically it is a
story of this guy basically it's in an
Arab country discarding want to be named
and he sends his story to the newspaper
so they can publish it so people can
learn a lesson out of it because the
stuff he went through also you know
you'd be shocked bro this guy he's in
college he meets a girl ends up doing
zina with her and basically a couple of
months later the brothers find out come
machina is door trying to attack him and
say blah blah blah you did this kind of
stuff here and this this guy hell away
from him I remove your sister go find a
pregnancy somewhere else
yunchan see so she's pregnant
yes she's pregnant spoonula and so what
happened is these mobs didn't have
nothing on him
so what could he do - can't do nothing
or evidence so they left him went so
what this lover says is in the news he's
based in the newspaper he's like couple
years went by I was in University and
one day he goes I left I was I left uni
and I'll just on my way home I came home
and I found my mom on the floor
I just wanna know what's going on
because I've grabbed my mom and I said
mom what's what's what's happening are
you okay to go he goes oh look in the
working memory she's screaming and she
just passes out and I'm trying to wake
her up she was this it was happened a
couple of times and he goes when when
she finally woke up Xuan your sister I
just wanna know what happened to her
what she got killed or something there
and he goes your sister and I God mom
what happened to my sister because his
sister fell pregnant by the neighbor
whoa because it sound and he goes he
lost the control so what he did was he
ran to the neighbor's house obviously
broke the door whatever stop attacking
this guy here boss Panola this guy goes
that guy said one word that went through
my heart like a dagger he said to me go
find your sister's pregnancy somewhere
else it's got nothing to do with me it's
got nothing to do with me because it
made me remember same words I said to
that girl couple of years ago
not only does in here when I look at is
he already shot Robbie doesn't in there
what happens is next is couple years ago
parts and this guy says he goes from
mental illness for him because they're
not met like you know frustration
because of what happened to me the big
so happens he ends up you know gonna get
married to his Brides fine a lot and on
the marriage day the his wife comes and
says communi before spawn a lot and he
goes he goes it's just the guy you know
please don't expose my sin and my other
small town I won't expose you on the day
of judgment said that him yep she says
that Jim please here he goes
because its final luck because he goes
you know please you know how much more
can I take her
you know he's seen talisman Tyler and he
goes I had to take that upon me and I do
not swallow it and I had to carry on
because many years past I had a
beautiful daughter six years old he goes
he says it there specifically because
she was like the moon you know he
describes one of Marshall
basically he goes one day we came home
obviously in our country they could have
a guard or something yeah because my
daughter were not to me and I it's
really getting to me - finally he goes
my Torah not to me and those the god
raped me the god raped can you believe
it
so finally it was and this is this is
this is what we trying to say boy you
know cause in the Quran Allah so Allah
says you plan yeah yeah I plan this book
and I am the best of planners and this
verse I will touch upon what I'm trying
to say yeah because what happened here
is this problem the girl he committed
zina with had a brother he had to suffer
that pain
Alice Paulette Allah made the same
happened to his sister so he can feel
the same from what happened to the
girl's brother that sister was gonna get
married one day and she was gonna have
to explain to her husband that she
committed zina here so Alice want Allah
made her marry a woman that's committing
zina so he can feel the same pain as
what that woman Rafi that sister had a
father how would the father feel man how
would the father feel that's why last
moment Allah punished him through his
daughter as a father so he can
understand
that's deep Rob that was really deep so
basically they were it's basically
reciprocate it's gonna come back bro it
will come a lot smaller in sport Allah
is jealous jealous of his women yeah he
will vengeance don't think the reason
why I said Alice want are the plans you
guys know you plan and I was more tired
of plans and he's the best of planners
is because you get these brothers out
there saying I check my sister's phone
now I see where she's going I follow her
she can't do nothing like that
you try to fool who are you trying to
fool you know unless poet Allah the
Almighty man the one who created you
you're gonna be catcher well I hear
stories that sisters they're on lockdown
and they still do it yeah you know let
me see that let me not hijab you guys
they still doing your fallen I was
bought on a would punish you yeah you
thinking about then do that other people
sitting that's not gonna happen to you
he dreaming man just keep your dreams
scary man that's scary for for it that's
that's the mindset though that we should
carry in its image such a big thing when
you came in do you know only
transgressing against your soul yes you
transgression yeah you you you're
harming someone officers warning
it's not very very very powerful very
very deep very deep but even though it
is deep and even though okay look you
did it
McDonnell and you know obviously for
inshaallah from this you do take home
that you know uh yeah somehow didn't
know okay you didn't know what's the
next step then in it yeah you come today
you're alive in it yeah you're watching
this video if you are if not share it
out that you're still breathing in here
still alive Allah isn't taking a soul
yet yeah the doors of repentance are
open yeah you heard it for me and
brother pure you let guys be real man
come back to the real world you know
that's why you know it's a reality show
you know come back to real life
you know Valentine's Day is coming up
don't go around doing silly stuff come
on man you don't need that how many how
many stories are getting out of these
relationships to me son you'll be
shocked man like I said guys before you
click away just wait for the end of the
video because we've got four links that
will be interesting part 1 part 2 improv
your reality show also a little video of
renee manaman monster off the nasir
sessions it be straight after the video
finished Panola thank you very much for
watching please subscribe and all I want
from sisters out there is to share this
video and brothers and try to tag along
tag some people which can benefit from
the video as well just remember though
it takes two hands to clap so even
though our brothers come in and all that
yeah
Salam alaikum
Langella
City Power Shovel fun